( music playing )
( whistling )
( music continues )
( Tarzan yell )
( grunts )
All right, we're in.
You know the plan, right?
What am I saying?
You practically wrote it.
Everything you need is
in your bag,
so let's synchronize
our watches on three.
Three! Perfect.
Now, stick to the plan
and you'll be just fine.
But if you deviate from it
for even a single moment,
I won't come back for you.
Okay? Good luck!
( grunts )
Hey!
What do you think
you're doing?
Oh, no!
Not the old steak trick.
I'm not falling for that twice.
Yeah, put the steak down.
I'm not even gonna look
at the steak.
I'm looking at you
right in the eyes.
I looked at the steak.
Shh.
Nicely done, buddy.
All according to plan.
And speaking of plan,
looks like we are, uh,
eh, yeah.
We're moving on to phase two.
Are you ready? On my go.
Go!
( music playing )
Behind you. Behind you.
( man whistling )
He tracks the intruder,
quiet as a ninja
suppressing a fart in church.
( chuckles )
There she is.
Three-legged woman,
got you now.
Oh, this?
It's just my gun.
You're safe with me, ma'am.
( muttering, shouts )
I mean, who's there?
Come back!
Great job, buddy.
I'll meet you over there.
All right.
We are so close to the vault.
Come on.
Stay low and stay quiet.
Come on, this way.
We're almost there.
Checkmate.
- Okay. Oh, I can
almost taste it.
- ( lock beeps )
You wanna know my favorite thing
about this vault?
- Go on.
- You need two keys.
- One for you, one for me.
- All right, here we go.
- Ready? One, two, three.
- Both: Security!
( alarm chirps )
I love this job.
Oh, crap. Oh, crap.
This wasn't in the plans.
There are two keys
for this vault.
We need to get them from
those guards or any guards
that are moderately
less competent than those.
Why don't you go back
the way we came
and why don't I have
a little bit of a chat
with that guard over there.
Be back in a flash.
- ( clang )
- Aah! Oh!
Be back in a flash.
( clicks tongue )
( snorting )
( snarls )
( music playing )
- ( clang )
- ( screaming )
Okay.
Ooh!
Oh, you got a key.
I got one, too. Come on.
I think these are what
we need to get in that vault.
Oh, boy.
Oh, this is it.
You ready?
Now on three.
- One--
- ( buzzer )
What the hell?
Ah, whatever.
( buzzer )
After you.
( alarm chirps )
Oh, this is it.
This is really it.
- ( glass shatters )
- This is what we've
been working towards
all those years.
It's finally ours.
This is gonna change
our lives forever.
- ( alarm blaring )
- Ah, crap.
Um, it's fine.
Uh, this is why we plan.
Oh! Okay, I see two ways
out of here.
There just so happens
to be a sewer
that runs directly
beneath this vault.
I supposed we could've
gone in that way,
but that doesn't matter.
We could either go through
the sewer all sneaky like,
or we could go out
guns blazing.
Yeah, I found these bad boys
in the pirate exhibit
on the way over here,
but we gotta choose fast.
I think they're on the way
and they're not
gonna be friendly
when we're in here
with the box
and the bomb and the gun.
So, either one's good.
Sewer will probably work
all quiet like,
but, you know,
I like a little action.
But stealth is good, too.